et puisque l'on parle d' ado pacifique
je vais pas m'empêcher de dire que la
défaite du 1er mai horribilis morrison
ne convient très bien
parce que les actes posés à l'égard de
la france
au moment où ils ont été posées
étaient d'une brutalité d'un cynisme et
seront même tenté de dire d'une forme
d'incompétence notoire
et ça me fait plaisir vous le dire ce
soir et je sais pas si je ne sais pas si
il a pensé la concordance ou la
concomitance des dates mais si il y à
penser si bien pour lui il n'ya pas
pensé moi c'est tant pis pour lui
j'espère que nous pourrons renouer avec
l'australie un dialogue franc et
constructif dans l'avenir en tout cas je
le souhaite madame la ministre